qu'est-ce que ça colle à la télé en
championnat sur des rh monsieur aussi
décoratif que vous amenez le label c'est
notre fils baptiste ou quoi mais c'est
le style de touba mais oui oui mais pas
les mains mais vous pouvez le mettre
attendez attendez là ya pas de bisou
comme sa pratique est ce que vous pouvez
faire à une amoureux mais alors là on
est ici on oublie tout souci si la
nouvelle était plat tout simple en boule
d ici tout ce qui se passe dans touche
pas à mon poste reste dans touche pas à
ça ne sort pas dit si on touche pas à
mon poste vous appuyez sur les insultes
avec votre visite fait passer en dehors
de le
et fait attention on va avoir des
problèmes avec otis bâtisse est ce que
vous voulez bien vraiment faire un kiff
à isabelle morini bosc est une de mes
personnes préféré au monde grossesse
mais là on va mettre non une grosse
pelle c'est pas parce qu'il a fait
quelques travaux dans une chanson
ces caches
là pour le coup on prend l'ascenseur et
on descend d'accord wasquehal b alors
c'est ce qu'on pouvait mettre un seul ou
baptiste vous vous déplacez et vous
allez invités jeanne d'arc accord est là
où fait qu'un seul homme est très serré
avec isabelle morini-bosc l'essai est
actif et salses l'on attendait qu'ils
vous invitent à venir et il est où la
cabine
j'adore c'est en train d'exciter les
cons ça c'est un second but
oh là là le
ouais
alors perdu l affaire du poilu la boucle
d'oreille
qu'est ce qu'il a bâti ce titre a été
vous avez qui fait j'adore alors comment
ça s'est passé
il sent bon c'est beau saint-cyrille on
regarde ça a été tout ça peut m'excite
cbd sous bois ouais ouais elle est
traitée dans un curriculum vitae c'est
de faire des blagues un peu plus venir
l'eau